just two months into joe biden's
presidency and already the
administration has lost control of our
main international border
entire populations are moving north
through mexico tonight
just last month u.s customs and border
protection apprehended a hundred
thousand
illegal migrants in california new
mexico arizona and texas
but some dhs officials believe that
number will soon double
to 200 000 a month moving illegally into
this country
now the overwhelming majority of these
foreign nationals will remain here
permanently
if the democratic party has its way they
will become citizens and registered
voters
these numbers are enormous it's hard to
comprehend just how big
we've never seen demographic change like
this it's roughly the equivalent
of a brand new city of chicago every
year
a city populated entirely by poor people
with limited education who can't speak
english
now you're not supposed to say any of
that but so what
it's true and the question is how is it
good for america
we live in a deeply fractured country on
the cusp of an economic crisis
so how will an unprecedented surge of
millions of low-skilled foreign
nationals
strengthen the american economy how will
it unite our society which badly needs
it
honestly we'd love to hear someone
answer these questions
calmly and at length they're the only
questions that matter
spare us the lecture about how opposing
open borders is racist
the all hispanic counties of south texas
don't like open borders either they made
that very clear in the way they voted in
november
the people responsible for these
decisions for this crisis don't want to
talk about it and they don't want you to
ask questions
if you do they'll denounce you for
attacking immigrants
please nobody thinks it's the immigrants
fault
you can't blame poor people for wanting
to come here who wouldn't come who among
us
free education free health care clean
streets safety
you'd have to be crazy not to leave
guatemala for texas so of course they
are
the people streaming across the border
want better lives for their families and
no one can hate them for that least of
all us
the people to blame are the reckless
ideologues who
caused this disaster joe biden tops that
list
biden wanted this to happen he said so
out loud at a democratic debate
i would in fact make sure that there is
we immediately surge to the border
all those people are seeking asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
where a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing oppression
you should come you should come
said joe biden to millions of the
world's poorest people
joe biden promised him the world's best
medical care for free
he pledged not to deport anyone he told
them they would make
better americans than the americans who
were born here and of course they heard
him
the moment joe biden took off as many
thousands began the journey north
some of them arrived at the border
wearing joe biden t-shirts and demanding
to be let in
they are happy to explain why they came
this father who asked that we not show
his face traveled to mexico from brazil
with his wife and three young kids
before crossing the border
would you have tried to do this when
donald trump was president
definitely not so did you come here
because joe biden was elected president
basically basically uh the main thing
was the violence in my country
and the second thing i think was joe
biden
so they're running from collapsing
countries they're running
toward joe biden you could have seen
this coming
senior officials at customs and border
control did see it coming and they
warned the white house
that a human disaster was on the way the
policies changed and the rest of the
world
responded you knew it was going to
happen but the byte administration
ignored them and then it doubled down
announcing a mass amnesty and an
end to the deportation of unaccompanied
minors
any young person who enters our country
alone will be allowed to stay so not
surprisingly many of them came
as of tonight there are over 15 000
so-called
unaccompanied minors in u.s custody
waiting to be processed
not all of them are children or even
minors at least 5 000 of them are
teenagers up to at least the age of 17
but there's no real way to know how old
they are
or even who they are because that's the
nature of illegal immigration
and that's why functional countries use
visas
once again this is a human tragedy for
everyone involved the migrants making
their way through mexico which hates
them and mistreats them
and a tragedy for those of us who live
here what's amazing
is that even as this crisis appeared on
the horizon
the bible administration seemed totally
unprepared for it once it arrived
add incompetence to their growing list
of sins they had no idea what they were
doing
as of tonight there are no more beds in
border facilities we have long
past the point of not enough so just
today dhs
announced plans to turn the san diego
convention center
into a migrant shelter other migrants
will be given hotel rooms
according to axios the administration
plans to spend at least
90 million dollars on lodging for people
coming here illegally
think about that at a time when there
are more than half a million
americans homeless living on the streets
a crushing number
that our leaders ignore but that rises
every single year
at that moment joe biden is giving hotel
rooms to illegal aliens
it's hard to believe that it's real oh
but it is real
those migrants who can't get a hotel
room or live in downtown san diego or
fly at public expense to processing
facilities on the canadian border
are simply being released into the
country so this is what open borders
actually looks like chaos how chaotic is
it
tonight we can only see the outlines of
it because the bite administration is
keeping journalists at a distance
they don't want the public to see too
much their excuse of course
is covid it always is watch the dhs
secretary explain
right now we have no access to or photos
of the conditions in the facilities
there have been no right alongs with
agents all inquiries are routed through
washington there have been strict
controls on sharing data
local border patrol folks feel like they
can't even talk to our folks down there
is there a gag order
there there is not that is unequivocally
uh false
chuck and let's let's be clear here we
are in the midst of a pandemic
we are because of the extraordinary
leadership of the president
climbing out of it more rapidly than
ever before
but we are still in the midst of the
pandemic
oh so there's a pandemic and that means
border patrol agents can't do phone
interviews
right so here you have the
administration telling journalists that
there's a once-in-a-lifetime news event
underway something that will change this
country forever
but they're not allowed to cover it
sorry your cameras might hurt us
politically
how can the press corps reply to this
this is the president they wanted and
worked for
reporters who spent the last four years
pushing with increasing hysteria for
media censorship
so it's not as if they can stand on
principle and demand openness now
they wanted fascism and they got it
still you'd think someone at nbc might
laugh
when majorca cited kovid kovid really
isn't this the same guy who's been
releasing illegal migrants into
our country without even testing them
for coronavirus
yes it is watch
there were times earlier
when individuals were apprehended
and we sought to expel them and we were
unable to expel them
and we were compelled to release them
and we did not have the opportunity to
test them
somehow nobody in the press corps
thought to note the irony of that
the guy who's releasing migrants
illegally
into our country without even testing
them for covet is using covet as a
pretext for keeping the press from
knowing what they're actually doing
no one mentioned it nor is anyone in
washington yelling about kids in cages
anymore remember kids in cages
for a long time it was all they could
talk about
i'm going to immediately without
exception
close down every one of those
cages and camps where they have because
guess what
people were still showing up before they
don't have to be put in cages or
separated from their mothers
comprehensive immigration reform with a
pathway towards citizenship but for
on first day one get those babies out of
those cages
we're not going to lock any families
we're not going to separate families
we're not going to put any kids in cages
they have had a policy of having babies
in cages and separating children
from their parents in the name of border
security
when in fact what it is is a human
rights abuse being committed by the
united states government
i don't believe we're a nation that puts
kids in cages and thinks it's okay
kids in cages they wrote the talking
point and they just kept repeating it as
always it was the ultimate civil rights
atrocity so you've got to ask
how are those kids doing under the joe
biden administration we can't answer
that question with any
certainty because as we just told you
they are blocking our cameras
we're not allowed to see what they don't
want us to see
but thanks to democratic congressman
henry cuellar a surprising hero
in this story we do have a few
photographs of detention facilities
taken from the inside
you can't see cages exactly but there
are a lot of young people living in what
appear to be
cellophane cells is that an improvement
it's hard to see how it is
joe biden doesn't seem all that
interested either way yesterday he
suggested he'll get to the border
at some point are you thinking of going
to the border
at some point i will yes do you want to
see firsthand what's going on in those
facilities
i know what's going on in those
facilities
yeah like he does nancy pelosi isn't
scurrying down to south texas either she
doesn't need to she already knows how
great illegal immigrants are they work
in her vineyard in napa
they work cheap and they're good people
in fact they're far better people than
you
are so keep that in mind when they come
here with their hopes and dreams and
aspirations
these parents bringing their children
their hopes and dreams and aspirations
for a better future for their children
that courage that determination
those aspirations are american traits
and they all make america more american
with all of that indeed they are true
and legitimate heirs these dreamers are
of our founders if you set up a system
where people don't get to run stuff
until they're really old
so rich they have no connection to the
country itself they've been living in
complete isolation for decades
a system like that produces people like
the one you just saw who say things like
that
foreign nationals who break our laws are
the quote true and legitimate heirs of
america
in other words it's not your country
it's theirs and why wouldn't she feel
that way
migrants work cheap they don't complain
or form unions or go on disability or
celebrate all those stupid holidays like
you do
they're grateful for the chance not to
live in honduras and that's why people
like nancy pelosi love
them and it's not just nancy pelosi
we're sad to tell you it's not just
democrats
we told you last week about a bill
called the farm workforce modernization
act
it would give amnesty to at least a
million immigrants
who are here illegally as long as they
can prove that they've worked in
agriculture for just 180 days over the
previous
two years it's absurd that's the price
of citizenship 180 days working in
agriculture
it's gotten cheaper over time the
amazing thing is a total of 30 house
republicans voted for that bill why'd
they do that
you know why lobbyists for cheap labor
got to them and that's just
one amnesty bill that republicans are
backing
yet another introduced by freshman
republican maria elvira salazar a
favorite of kevin mccarthy's
would provide daca recipients with quote
immediate legal status and a pathway
forward to citizenship
over the us senate meanwhile florida
senator rick scott is trying something
very similar he's preparing to introduce
a bill
to give millions of people here
illegally amnesty and work permits
now for the people getting those
benefits this is very good news
good for them but how does it help you
and your neighbors
as the country that we grew up in
teeters on its foundations
no one seems even to be asking that
question because nobody cares
tonight we will ask it